hello everyone and welcome to the rapid
and blitz paris tournament it's a very
nice game between yanni ponichi and
wesley saw the game you've all been
waiting for because wesley seems to be
unstoppable this tournament and
jan is well as strong as he is he's the
challenger to world champion magnus
carlson
the match will take place in november if
you guys were wondering
uh and it's just a really really
impressive game so without further ado
let's check it out as nippo
opens with b3 he goes for the nimzo
larson opening
uh we have d5 by wesley knight bishop to
b2
uh and now knight to f6 with e3 and
bishop to f5
wesley a big fan of developing the light
square bishop early uh
in many openings you know be mindful of
that we have knight to f3
and now e6 he wants to play c6 close off
the structure put all of his pawns on
light squares have a dark square bishop
that he can use to go
in between the pawns and then the light
square bishop will not be a problem so
you don't have to
worry about developing it later uh here
we have c4
attacking the center and c6 now wesley
defense we have knight to c3
and knight b to d7 now we have d4
and now another use case of the bishop
on f5
knight to e4 and this is an excellent
square for the knight so now if this
knight captures you can capture back
with the bishop you don't have to ruin
your pawn structure
and here known moves are knight captures
on e4 and
knight to d2 but here nipple plays a3
and it is already as of move 8 that we
have a completely new game
so let's see how wesley continues with
bishop to d6 he simply continues
development we have bishop to d3
nepal does the same and now a series of
trades here knight captures bishop
captures bishop captures and queen
captures so
taking off two two pairs of pieces of
the board and queen to e7 developing the
queen
now saying i might castle king side i
might castle queen side but
it's probably going to be king side
because there's a storm storm coming on
the queen
side so here we have castles by nippo
and now
a5 preventing those pawns from being
pushed
forward right away we have e4 now saying
okay your king is still in the center of
the board it's a very principled idea i
want to open up the center
and here you kind of can grab the a3
pawn but not really if
you go for that pawn just c5 traps the
bishop there's no no saving it now
so instead wesley just castles here and
here we have
bishop back to b2 by nepo uh
now the 8th report is nicely definite
and maybe later on in the future maybe
you can get some queen to c3
action going on depends on what how the
situation in the center resolves
uh we have d captures on e4 queen
captures and now
knight to f6 this is how you activate
the knight with tempo now the queen has
to move
queen to h4 and now wesley strikes on
the queen side with b5 so it's still a
very very level
game both players with their dark square
bishops both dark square bishops are
very strong
uh so for the moment uh definitely an
equalish game
so bishop to c1 now nipple wants to get
this bishop over to g5
and wesley just captures here b captures
on c four b
captures and c five so with this move uh
yes wesley does give nepo a past uh c
pawn if for example nepal trades but
then he's gonna blockade with the bishop
here
and it's not gonna be easy removing that
bishop and start pushing the the past
pawn
uh but nipple goes a4 instead and now
rook f the c8 now wesley says all right
i might just capture here maybe double
up on the c file go after your c for
pawn
uh let's see let's see how you defended
nipple goes bishop to e3
and c captures on d4 we have bishop
captures and
now rook a to b8 so this rook can now
come to b4 it can come to b3
all depends on what white plays and also
just the c4 pawn is under attack so here
bishop back to c3 now the queen defends
the pawn
and now bishop to b4 now uh wesley's
saying okay you can capture here and
then i get
my my pass pawn so here bishop back to
e5 attacking the rook once again and now
bishop back to d6 wesley wants to trade
off the dark square bishops
and rook f2d1 now with a double attack
here on the bishop so here wesley
finally trades it
uh bishop captures knight captures and
the queen to c7 now
with an attack on this and this knight
here and here there are a couple of
moves you you could play
uh one such move is queen to d4 just
getting the queen back into the game a
nice centralizing move
uh but nipple plays queen to g5 and it's
so
it's a it's a weird move to say the
least it's it's
again an active move for the queen maybe
he's hoping for some rook lifts in the
future
putting indirect pressure here on the a5
pawn uh but
wesley just plays a queen to c5 and uh
what do you do now
well if the knight now moves to a weird
place uh first off you just lose the
queen
so queen to f4 now this knight can move
because queen captures on f7 is
happening and
also the rook on b8 is being indirectly
attacked so if this rook ever moves you
might
run into some discovery so rook the b7
uh getting the rook out of the way while
defending the f7 pawn
so here uh h3 taking a moment to create
a breeding room for the king
and wesley does the same with h6 and now
only now
nipple goes for the rook lift rook to d3
now you can play rook to f3 rook to g3
put some pressure on black's king side
so rook c to b8 now with ideas of
trading off a pair of rooks
but also just rook to b2 will be very
interesting as the queen also attacks
the f2 pawn
so king to h2 and now rook to b2
so the f2 pawn is attacked twice now
comes rook to f3 defending it
and now queen back to c7 now again
uh with uh with an indirect attack on
white's queen
so here we have rook to e1 adding
another defender to the knight
and now comes rook to a2 going after the
a4 pawn
but also just making room for the other
rook to come to b2 but this gives nipple
a very important tempo to get his pieces
back into the game so queen g3 now
again with tempo now rook captures on f6
is a threat
because the the pawn here will not be
able to capture so wesley needs the
waist to move the side step with the
king king h7 this is the only good move
for black wesley plays it
and now queen to h4 again getting the
queen off of this diagonal but still
it's very ugly having your king here
with with the queen and c7 so here
rogue beat to b2 now with a double
attack on the f2 pawn for the moment
it's defended
but things uh you know change you very
very quickly
and here you should definitely bring the
queen back queen to d4 this queen needs
to be centralized but
uh he doesn't care uh he just plays a
rook e to e3 adds another
rook to the third rank and now he's
basically offering a pawn to wesley if
wesley wants to weaken
his king a little bit for example with
the g5 then you can remove the defender
of the f2 pawn
uh for example queen d4 we can just
capture here and if captures captures
and it's a very nice position for black
but it's not a
yeah it's not a directly winning one so
wesley of course doesn't want to
uh go into this and then use unnecessary
time so wesley starts with rook to e2
he just wants to pile up on this knight
here uh and now of course if you capture
then it's game over captures captures
there's no way to defend
this knight it's attacked twice already
so instead after rook to e2 we have
queen to d
for now uh but now comes rook captures
on f2
uh we have rook captures rook captures
and now nepal says
okay now we've pretty much uh
you know are done with everything we
wanted to do
and now i'm down upon but i have a past
c pawn and i'm gonna start pushing it
because
these squares are nicely protected so he
pushes c5
but now knight to d5 attacking the rook
here we
rook the g3 and look at the position now
when the rook moved to g3 this rook is
under attack
the g7 pawn uh will very soon be under
attack
if this knight moves could be very
deadly and nipple enjoys his position
however the position is completely lost
for him
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find uh
basically the only real winning move for
wesley while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
again noticing that your rook is hanging
and we need to move it with
tempo and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's rook to f4 and
now uh all of
nippo's uh ideas will no longer
will no longer be uh you know of any
value
uh here the queen is under attack queen
back to b2 and now comes
rook to f5 you could also play f6 but
wesley says no point in ruining our pawn
structure let's just attack the knight
this way
there's no way to defend the knight so
you can only move the knight so knight
to f3
and now comes knight to f6 and now this
spin here
will be everlasting knight to h5 is
coming and you will not be able to save
the rook here
so queen to b6 basically the only move
to prolong the game and now wesley
doesn't even
want to torture nipple or maybe he just
didn't want to lose time but here if you
move the queen
and he goes after it again e5 and that's
it there's no defense you can just
attack the rook on the next move and
it's game over
but wesley said nope i'm very happy
going into an endgame i'm now up two
pawns and i
am very easily winning this there's no
point in complicating matters so here
if you trade then like i said it's
completely winning for black you wrap
two pawns so instead after rook captures
on c5 we have queen to b1
uh now delivering this check here king
to g8 and now knight
to d4 trying something but there is
nothing to be done here
wesley just attacked the rook here
knight to h5
and there is no move here you can play
knight to e2
and here wesley just captured knight
captures on g3 and he was in this
position on mu 45 that yanni pony should
resign the game
and a brilliant brilliant victory for
wesley so uh who is simply on a rampage
in this tournament
so here yes you're down some material
but the the win
is so simple that i know i know players
who would win this
for example on leeches with one second
on the clock
this is such a simple position to win
because you just have to trade
for example after white trades you're
gonna attack the pinned piece and
there's no more white can make
white can only defended the knight here
and then you just trade everything off
captures captures captures and captures
and now you start bringing the king into
the game and of course you wrap two
pawns this is completely winning
so uh i'm i'm saying like with one
second on the clock some some people can
win this
uh but yeah after night captures on g3
of course yon also knows this and uh
here he resigned the game
uh so really impressive stuff and before
i forget these are the final standings
of the tournament
so wesley so wins the tournament full
three points
ahead of yaniponishi which is just
incredible uh
he he was simply unstoppable this
tournament and
well the the this is the result three
points ahead of the world championship
challenger that is
that is a no small feat uh so yeah
nipple with 21 and a half uh then we
have ferruja and
maxim bashar al-agrav with 18 out of 36
sharing third place basically
then levon and richard report with 17
and a half
petersfielder with 17 fabiana caruana
with 16 and a half
temura java with 14 uh and are wild
cards etienne bakr and vladimir kramer
who only each played
half of the tournament uh 10 points and
five and a half points
uh so yeah that's the game and the
tournament if you guys have any of your
favorite games that we've missed do use
hashtag suggestions i'm gonna go
through them as uh we all enjoy great
games uh but yeah
uh that's it for now uh i would like to
thank james o'toole philosophical
questions youtube
eric labelle alexander williamson and
kyle body for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day